we the medical profession are absolutely
tied
to knowing the name tumor and its
position
its anatomical position before we can treat it.
But we no longer do that with Lipitor
where we treat
or prevent heart attacks and
we really don't have to know the anatomical
position of the plaques
but we did, not now.
And we are no longer tied to knowing that
position or the type of infection
we often just treat the white blood count
and so forth.
So the question is can you treat cancer like
that
and
it's not clear but we
think there's a way to do that
when tumors switch on angiogenesis
that was that
that idea came in
the nineties when they switch on angiogenesis
having been non angiogenic for years
we have all everyone's assumed that that's
permanent
and now we found that about five percent can switch
it off and go backwards
and they're doing it all the time
but you can't tell because most of the tumor cells
are angiogenic so the tumor goes on
growing sixty seventy eighty percent of cells
are angiogenic, but small group is switching
backwards
going to non angiogenic
so that's a very important
finding the reversal of angiogenesis
so if nature can do it
we would just like to increase the percentage.
Well I think they'll be used
first of all
more, more widely in combination right now
of course have to be tested alone
with chemotherapy and without it
and gradually they're being combined
because the inhibitors we have are
very very tremendous breakthroughs
but they generally are very narrow
so they treat like
VEGF or one angiogenic factor but
tumors
keep adding things they keep
using different angiogenic factors
proteins
and it will be useful to
combine these
and after
we, the profession learns that experience,
like we used to use
in the forties we used to use penicillin by itself
you wouldn't do that today
you'd have penicillin plus something else
or three drugs
then the next step will be this to
move over to the very broad
angiogenesis inhibitors
none of them are in a clinic yet but they've
been discovered.
and we have calreticulin is one
and endostatin is another
and there are twenty six others in the body.
The angiogenesis inhibitors are approved in
twenty eight countries now besides the US
so we're learning first of all that
there's very little, very few side effects
so the patients find it very comfortable to
be treated for cancer
that's the first
huge change
and they do not want to go back another other
treatments
so we have patients who to play golf
get their strength back, go back to work and yet
are being treated every day with an angiogenesis
inhibitor.
The second thing we found is that
there's less drug resistance
with standard chemotherapy so they can
keep taking these drugs
patients have on
thalidomide five years for multiple biloma
on endostatin for three and a half years
for other tumors
so that, that's
very exciting to the oncologists.
And then the third
thing is that when you have treatment that's nontoxic,
or relatively nontoxic
so that you can give it for a long time like
tamoxifen,
that raises a question of whether
if you could diagnose the tumor
really early
by a
blood test,
a bowel marker or urine test
then maybe you could
treat the blood tests
and never see the tumor.
This is all in the future
but that's what
scientists have to
to
you have to actually
imagine what it might be if you can get there.